.
Es gibt aktuell eine wichtige
Diskussion in Deutschland.
Nämlich unser
Bundesgesundheitsminister
möchte die Regelung
zur Organspende ändern.
Was bedeutet das genau?
Es ist gut, dass ihr hier seid.
Nehmt euch ein bisschen Zeit.
Denn egal, ob ihr Organe spenden
möchtet oder nicht -
es ist wichtig,
dass ihr euch auskennt.
Denn nur ihr könnt über
euren eigenen Körper entscheiden.
Nur was ist die richtige
Entscheidung? Das klären wir jetzt.
* Titelmelodie *
Eines ist sicher:
Wir werden alle sterben.
Super Einstieg...
Und egal,
ob wir jung oder alt sterben -
unsere Organe
könnten nach unserem Tod verhindern,
dass andere Menschen sterben müssen.
Wenn ich also Organspender bin,
erkläre ich mich jetzt zu Lebzeiten
dazu bereit, dass nach meinem Tod
Organe oder Gewebe entnommen
werden dürfen.
Also mein Herz könnte nach meinem Tod
in der Brust eines anderen
Menschen weiter schlagen.
Und dieser Mensch hätte auch,
außer dieser Organspende,
derzeit keine andere
Alternative zum Überleben.
Das bedeutet:
Derzeit warten in Deutschland über
10.000 Menschen auf ein Spenderorgan.
Doch wir haben
nicht genügend Organspender,
und die Zahl sinkt auch noch. Und
das ist ein Problem.
Nun gibt es nachvollziehbare Gründe,
keine Organe spenden zu wollen.
Manche Menschen finden,
ihr Körper ist nun einfach mal
kein Ersatzteillager.
Das ist ein legitimer Gedanke.
Und letztendlich gehört mir
mein Körper alleine
und nur ich darf darüber entscheiden.
Manche Menschen trauen der
Organspende einfach nicht so recht.
Viele erinnern sich noch an den
Transplantationsskandal 2012.
Da gab es einen leitenden Arzt
an der Uniklinik Göttingen,
der hatte Krankenakten
und Wartelisten verfälscht.
Damit manche Menschen,
die auf ein Organ warten,
schneller an dieses Organ kommen
und andere
in der Warteliste runterrutschen.
Was natürlich Leben kosten kann.
Und auch in anderen Krankenhäusern
wurden danach
ähnliche Manipulationsfälle bekannt.
Nach diesem Skandal wurden die Regeln
und Kontrollen verschärft,
um zu vermeiden, dass so etwas
in Zukunft noch mal passieren kann.
Doch das Misstrauen blieb.
Allerdings zeigt uns dieser
Transplantationsskandal auch:
Ein großer Teil des Problems
liegt darin,
dass zu viele Menschen
auf zu wenige Spenderorgane warten.
Das Schädliche an dem Skandal
war sicher auch,
dass sich Menschen gefragt haben:
Kann ich Ärzten
überhaupt noch vertrauen?
Also nicht nur als Patient,
der auf ein Spenderorgan wartet,
sondern auch als jemand,
der bereit ist, Organe zu spenden.
Viele haben folgende Angst:
Wenn ich jetzt mich bereiterkläre,
Organe zu spenden,
werde ich dann schneller und
bereitwilliger für tot erklärt,
wenn mir etwas passiert?
Oder werden lebensrettende
Behandlungen vielleicht abgebrochen,
damit man schneller
an meine Organe kommt?
Das ist nachvollziehbarerweise
die häufigste Angst,
die die Menschen haben,
die keine Organe spenden möchten.
Doch diese Angst
muss man in Deutschland nicht haben.
Hierzulande dürfen Organe nur
entnommen werden, wenn 2
unabhängige Ärzte zweifelsfrei
den sogenannten Hirntod feststellen.
Was es genau bedeutet,
dazu komme ich gleich noch.
Nur das führt dazu,
dass es genau andersrum ist.
D.h., anstatt dass Menschen
vorschnell
zur Organspende herangezogen werden,
passiert in der Praxis
genau das Gegenteil.
Weil die Anforderungen an
diese Hirntod-Diagnose so hoch sind,
fallen viele potentielle
Organspender weg.
Denen dürfen
gar keine Organe entnommen werden,
Weil viele Krankenhäuser
nicht das Fachpersonal haben,
um diesen Hirntod festzustellen.
Das muss man hier schon dazu sagen.
Das Problem ist nicht nur,
dass wir nicht genügend Organspender
haben in Deutschland,
sondern dass unsere Krankenhäuser
nicht die Möglichkeit haben,
den Hirntod
zweifelsfrei festzustellen.
Und auch dann dürfen
eben keine Organe entnommen werden.
Falls ihr immer noch beunruhigt seid:
Die medizinischen Richtlinien
wurden seit 2015 noch mal verschärft.
Und die Hirntod-Diagnose ist
wissenschaftlich unumstritten.
Also Verifizierungen dazu findet ihr
auch in der Video-Beschreibung.
Nur was heißt jetzt Hirntod genau?
Beim Hirntod handelt es sich
um einen irreversiblen,
also nicht umkehrbaren Ausfall
des Gehirns.
Diese Todesart ist aber recht selten.
Meistens haben wir
Tod durch Herzstillstand,
und dann dürfen in Deutschland
keine Organe entnommen werden.
D.h., die meisten Menschen kommen als
Organspender ohnehin nicht infrage.
Da auf den Hirntod
auch der Herzstillstand folgt,
und dann auch irgendwann
die Organe kaputtgehen würden,
also auch nicht mehr brauchbar wären
für eine Transplantation,
werden Hirntote,
wenn sie denn Organspender sind,
künstlich beatmet.
D.h., das Herz schlägt auch noch,
der Tote ist warm.
Das kann für die Angehörigen ziemlich
heftig und belastend sein.
Es hat aber mit einem Koma oder so
nichts zu tun.
Man ist unwiederbringlich tot.
Das waren jetzt die medizinischen
Voraussetzungen für eine Organspende.
Da kann man sicher fragen:
Organspende rettet Leben,
warum macht man Organspende
nicht einfach zur Pflicht?
Wenn wir doch zu wenige
Spender haben.
Na ja, auch,
wenn es keine rationalen Gründe gibt,
keine Organe zu spenden -
Tod und Trauer
sind ja nicht rational.
Vielleicht möchte ich einfach nicht
ohne Herz z.B. im Sarg liegen.
Ich brauche das
jetzt zwar nicht mehr,
aber das können
trotzdem viele nachvollziehen.
Oder wir haben bei "Quarks"
eine ganze Sendung zur Organspende
gemacht, die verlinke ich euch unten.
An einer Stelle
ging es auch um die Angehörigen.
Und genau darum, wie krass das ist,
wenn da ein geliebter Mensch liegt,
der zwar tot ist,
das weißt du vielleicht rational,
aber der Mensch liegt da, der ist
warm, derart mit, das Herz schlägt.
- Eine Mutter, die ihren Sohn
zur Organspende freigegeben hat,
hat es im Nachhinein so formuliert,
dass sie sagt, mir wurde sozusagen
die Erfahrung des Todes genommen.
Sie sagt, "das letzte Bild,
das ich von meinem Kind habe,
ist das eines atmendes Kindes".
Und das macht es sehr viel schwerer,
den Abschied, den man einfach
nehmen muss, auch wirklich zu gehen.
- Aber vor allem wäre eine Pflicht
zur Organspende völlig inakzeptabel,
weil euer Körper euch alleine gehört.
Und nur ihr alleine darüber
entscheiden dürft.
Auch nach eurem Tod.
Damit kommen wir jetzt
zum relevanten Teil,
nämlich zur Entscheidung.
In Deutschland ist die Regelung
derzeit folgendermaßen:
Im Normalzustand, also per Default,
ist erst mal keine Organspende.
Nur, wenn ich ausdrücklich zustimme,
z.B. auf meinem Organspendeausweis,
dürfen wir nach dem Tod
Organe entnommen werden.
Unter den eben genannten
Voraussetzungen.
In anderen Ländern hingegen
gibt es die sogenannte:
D.h., per Default
ist erst mal jeder Organspender.
Es sei denn,
ich widerspreche ausdrücklich.
Übrigens kann man auch auf dem
Organspenderausweis widersprechen.
Das wissen viele nicht.
Also dieses Ding heißt nicht,
ja, ich bin Organspender,
dieses Ding heißt lediglich:
Ja, ich habe mich entschieden.
Also genau genommen
soll in Deutschland
eine doppelte Widerspruchslösung
eingeführt werden.
Das bedeutet,
ich bin automatisch Organspender,
es sei denn, ich widerspreche,
oder meine Angehörigen
widersprechen nach meinem Tod.
Deshalb doppelt.
Das Interessante ist jetzt:
Egal, welche Regelung gilt -
in jedem Fall
darf ich frei entscheiden.
Deswegen, warum diskutiert man
überhaupt so groß darüber?
Weil der Default,
also der Normalzustand,
einen großen Einfluss hat.
Sehr viele Menschen verbleiben
einfach im Default-Modus,
also im Normalzustand,
weil sie schlicht und einfach zu
träge sind, um sich darum zu kümmern.
Also man hat keine Zeit, sich die
Informationen einzuholen
oder einfach keine Lust,
über den Tod nachzudenken.
Alles nur verständlich.
Und weil auch viele Menschen
schlecht informiert sind,
empfindet man den Default,
also den Normalzustand,
als offizielle Empfehlung.
Und bleibt deswegen einfach dabei.
Der Default beeinflusst also
die Entscheidung der Menschen.
Und deshalb gibt es in Ländern
mit Widerspruchslösung
deutlich mehr Organspender.
Bei unseren Nachbarn in Österreich
herrscht die Widerspruchslösung
und die haben prozentual 2,5 Mal mehr
Organspender als hier in Deutschland.
In Spanien gibt es anteilig
fast 5 Mal so viele Organspender.
Das liegt nicht nur, aber auch,
an der Widerspruchslösung.
Ich persönlich bin eher
für die Widerspruchslösung.
Weil wir aus Umfragen wissen, dass
sehr viele Menschen in Deutschland
Organspende positiv sehen
und es zumindest deutlich
mehr Spender geben müsste,
als es derzeit der Fall ist.
Es gibt aber auch gute Gründe
gegen eine Widerspruchslösung.
Z.B. kann man argumentieren,
man darf einfach nicht
mit dem Körper eines anderen Menschen
irgendetwas machen
ohne dessen Zustimmung.
Deswegen ist es nur richtig,
dass man ausdrücklich zustimmen muss.
Doch eigentlich müssten wir
gar nicht darüber diskutieren,
wenn wir es stattdessen
irgendwie schaffen würden,
dass sich wirklich jeder
damit auseinandersetzt
und sich wirklich jeder entscheidet.
Denn wenn sich
jeder entscheiden würde,
dann hätten wir bereits
viel mehr potentielle Organspender.
Und eine wichtige Sache
darf man auch nicht vergessen:
In Deutschland werden
auch immer die Angehörigen gefragt.
- Formell ist der Patientenwille
das Entscheidende.
Aber wenn es darum
in der Familie Differenzen gibt
und Angehörige sind dagegen,
dann würde man nie um jeden Preis
eine Organspende durchziehen.
Im Idealfall ist es natürlich so,
dass man sich in der Familie
mit der Thematik befasst
und die nächsten Familienangehörigen
wissen,
wie der Patient entschieden hätte
und auch diesen Wunsch respektieren.
Dann gibt es
am wenigsten Reibungspunkte.
- Wenn man sich zu Lebzeiten nicht
mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt hat,
dann überträgt man diese schwere
Entscheidung auf seine Liebsten.
Und die wollte ich jetzt nicht nach
meinem Tod auch noch damit belasten.
Wir halten fest: In Deutschland
gibt es zu wenige Organspender.
Und ihr braucht eure Organe
nach dem Tod nicht mehr.
Wenn ihr Organe spenden möchtet,
dann haltet das fest.
Und auch, wenn ihr nicht spenden
möchtet, und das ist völlig okay,
dann haltet das auch fest.
Wo man so
einen Organspendeausweis bekommt,
findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung.
Z.B. kann man
dieses Ding online ausfüllen
und sich zu Hause ausdrucken.
Was auch funktioniert,
das wissen viele nicht:
Man kann auch einfach einen Zettel
mit den entsprechenden Infos
unterschreiben
und sich in den Geldbeutel legen. Das
funktioniert genauso.
Man kann auch
nur ein bestimmtes Organ spenden
oder bestimmte Organe ausschließen.
Prinzipiell kann man
folgende Organe spenden.
Das könnt ihr
auch in der Videobeschreibung lesen,
oder hier kurz pausieren.
Es gibt keinen wissenschaftlichen,
medizinischen
oder wenn man so will
rationalen Grund dafür,
bestimmte Gewebe nicht zu spenden.
Das ist auch wieder Teil
eurer Entscheidungsfreiheit
über euren Körper.
Was viele Organspender
tatsächlich hinschreiben, ist:
"Ich spende alles außer meine Augen."
Auch interessant, oder?
Denen ist natürlich auch klar,
dass sie ihre Augen
nicht mehr brauchen nach dem Tod.
Aber man hat dann doch irgendwie
so ein emotionales Verhältnis
zu seinem Körper.
Und für die kann man
vielleicht noch sagen,
dass die Augen
so sowieso nicht entnommen werden.
Man muss sich zumindest keine Sorgen
machen, dass man ohne Augen
oder mit eingefallenen Augenhöhlen
im Sarg liegt.
Von den Augen werden wie gesagt nur
Hornhaut oder Lederhaut entnommen.
Ich habe einen Organspendeausweis,
also einen ausgefüllten.
Und was da genau drauf steht,
ist völlig irrelevant.
Für euch.
Denn das ist
eine persönliche Entscheidung.
Ich will euch mit diesem Video keine
bestimmte Entscheidung empfehlen.
Sondern ich möchte euch nur bitten,
euch zu entscheiden.
Denn das ist die Hauptsache.
Zu einer guten Entscheidung gehört
natürlich, dass man sich auskennt.
Und deswegen hoffe ich,
dass dieses Video euch helfen konnte.
Falls ihr doch noch
offene Fragen haben solltet,
dann schaut in die Videobeschreibung.
Da habe ich euch
verlässliche Infos verlinkt.
Und z.B. wie gesagt
meine "Quarks"-Sendung zu dem Thema.
Letztes Jahr habe ich
das Thema auch behandelt,
findet ihr wie gesagt alles unten.
Ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche
oder in den Kommentaren.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher!
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2019)